even high just name you're like
do you feel like guys like do you do you
feel like guys like the girls not like
them
you think that's a true statement no
yeah no no they don't know I would say
they like to be violated small small
guys
but is this like
if you show that you don't want them
like that then they're gonna keep
persevering too but that's not true what
what do you mean it depends if I wanted
you in the first place yeah but if I
know you want me okay but I'm like that
might be age specific I won't lie
because if a woman should if a woman's
showing me nothing I'm not lying
anywhere that might be a beta man
mentality it's a reason
um
[Music]
I hate that term God I never thought she
is red
I I don't even I think those going guys
oh but the the alpha man he he knows
what he wants so if you act like you
don't want him like okay but cool
he's an agent thank goodness I'm I feel
so stupid that I just said those words
if a girl if you like a girl and she
acts super interested is it does that
ever turn you off no okay yeah no if you
like a girl and she acts stupid and she
and she acts like she's interested that
doesn't turn me off at all it's a level
of maturity yeah if you're a child I
want I want to see you like me
I want to see that as a man I want to
know that you like me if you're gonna
run then run I'm gone like you're going
to be running by yourself yeah well
that's maturity like certain guys they
they have about I'm not going to chase
you I don't chase I I chase in the
beginning if I see something I like I'll
Chase it if I see that you don't want me
to chase you I'll be gone I think that's
what most people though okay I don't
don't chase and be like
no I just feel like once um Once A girl
has been chased and she actually starts
to show the interest then he's like oh
whatever I can I can move on to the next
is there anything to that Sarah or did
he catch you and maybe he depends on
what he wanted if he wanted to just have
sex with you then yeah yeah he got what
he wanted yeah but it's not imagine
there's no sex he's like he's chasing
her he's trying to talk to her he's
doing whatever whatever he gets her she
starts she finally starts to talk and
then Kaboom he's like maybe he wanted to
show himself that he could still Chase
it shows that women just basically get
used
[Music]
but but girls do no girls go and get
free meals nowadays that's a bit crazy
it's not an anomaly it's like 56 of
women when surveyed admitted to it yeah
I feel like we have this whole I say
like disposable culture like literally
you could just toss anyone about like oh
I'll talk to you today tomorrow no so I
think that whole everything is in demand
plays into fact like you can go on an
app and get 10 girls today and then I
can download the app right now and get
vagina in half an hour
so that's the problem like back in the
days you actually have to meet someone
in an establishment or a friend of a
friend mom dad someone someone's going
to introduce you to someone whereas now
yeah but what are you looking for that's
the real question are are you looking
for a hookup or are you looking for a
relationship are you looking for
marriage are you looking for something
serious do you get what I mean so if
you're in an arena with guys who are
looking for a hookup and you're looking
for marriage it's not going to work is
it and then if you're going for girls
who are looking for a hookup and they're
gonna hit you up just to go on a date to
have a meal that's a bit mad you can
kind of tell when a woman doesn't like
you and she's just there for the meal
but then it's kind of a like a pat on
your back um a lot of girls know how to
act on a date like everything's cool you
know what I'm saying like
um they can act like everything's cool
and they're nice and then
yeah tomorrow they want if you won't
even hear from them but I think a lot of
guys have that understanding when they
go out out that they're gonna blow so
much cash on a girl I don't no okay
maybe type of woman why is that type of
woman you might not even know you and
this is what thing is me right
I said you're talking to a man who was
in that correlation for 10 years I am
very well versed in grand gestures I
know what a grand gesture is to my woman
I'll take you on a holiday I will buy
you things Valentine's Day birthday I
was very well versed in it I am coming
from that and I'm coming into a
marketplace where women want grand
gestures and I've just met you are you
crazy my woman got Grand Jesters I don't
know you let's go for a picnic in a park
and I'll have a talk with you do you
know what I mean and I'll see let's go
for a coffee and then I'll and I'll see
what's going on don't ask me for Grant
don't ask me to spend two three four
hundred pound in a restaurant at
hakkasan I don't know you yeah but you
see sorry it's so hot but like I like
the grand gestures however I don't
expect it from you if I say let's go
somewhere nice best believe I'm ready to
put in for that what do you mean we
haven't got time for what issue you want
to pay for me on a first date no no not
pay for you oh okay we wait all put in
every like let's go somewhere nice and
enjoy the food because I'm sorry like I
don't want to say I'm a bit bougie but
I'm a bit [ __ ] bougie and I don't I
don't like I can do picnic in the park
give me m s yes I'll do picnic in the
past in the park
I will provide the m s because that's
and she knows that's that's just what
I'm like I don't care like I don't I'm
not bothered about what you have what
you don't have like as long as
I'm happy in this like then I'm cool you
need to be by yourself
piss off like you do you need to be by
yourself
that's what I'm saying but you need to
be by yourself like you're you're acting
like the man in this no I'm not acting
like that man I'm acting like the man I
just I'm not gonna settle for BS because
someone doesn't want to give it to me
like give it to you what obligation do
they have to have it you don't have an
obligation to give it to me but if you
want something from me you're gonna have
to show me that I'm I'm actually worth
you even getting that okay well what are
you showing to him what am I sure yeah
like what are you sure what are you
doing I'm chasing you down what does he
get I'm a very intelligent woman I'm
very caring I can be very submissive
it's just that you you can be submissive
that's a choice it's a choice every
woman
I'm not going to submit to every man
that I meet no no no no submission
should be your default setting your
energy when it comes to men yeah you
can't because all right if I said as a
man I will only be masculine for the
right woman
but that's how it sounds to man when you
say I can be feminine or I can be
submissive they're like oh I don't want
to deal with that headache I'll just
find a girl who who is submissive
but like that sometimes just because if
I ask a guy to do something for me why
is it taking me 10 years right done like
today I've asked you the nicest way
possible cherry on top everything but
it's taking you 10 years now I have to
take it to my own initiative to do it on
my own yeah so when you keep doing that
when you have to keep doing certain
things by yourself you will have that
mindset of I will choose to when I will
choose when to be submissive if but
like I don't know the guys that you're
around like I said I'm I'm a little bit
older like I don't know but like I said
all I'm saying is
the expectation of a lot of women
um
one in certain things when I know as a
man what I can provide and what I have
provided in the past I'm just like
you're not you're not you don't deserve
that well I'll give you an example my
dad's a one percent guy so in the top
income earners he hit one percent he had
ten kids with my mom and if my mom
demanded these yeah sorry what he so
he's one percent earners like it's a
multi million yeah yeah he owns a
software company he's a lot of like
women would have overlooked him because
my a lot of wealthy successful men
aren't trying to spend money like that
my dad is cheap yeah he's not he's not
gonna spend a bunch of money on a [ __ ]
like I'm sorry he doesn't know you and
so and so then you're gonna put yourself
as too hot you're gonna put yourself
like in okay like and same with my
brothers all every single person in my
family makes six figures that is older
than me so all of my brothers they're
Engineers they're successful they're
tall they're good looking there there
are a lot of things that women want and
if and I'm telling you if they heard oh
I need to take you on a nice day or
we'll split it we have to go here
because you're making it about you and
so they're going to overlook you because
they're like well that just sounds like
a headache yeah like I'm gonna take the
nice like the nice girl that wants to
get coffee because she wants to get to
know me exactly because the date is
about a date right in my principle it's
about getting to know one another we can
get to know each other we don't have to
have a nice restaurant to get to know
each other I want to get to know you
want to get to know me we can do that in
a setting that's nice it doesn't have to
be sparkly and with you know diamonds
and crystals and all this kind of stuff
I wasn't talking about the hakasans
though notice I said we can go to a
picnic in the park but I just like m s
that's just me personally as a person so
at the end of the day like this is fun
even down to like when I have been
online and I've seen these weird men
that want to be doing up oh I'll take
you to this place I'll take you to that
place I find it unattractive I find it
scary I feel like you're trying to lure
me into something that's not real and
then you know what's a scary part I have
met and I'm sorry to make this personal
but I have met somebody online thank God
I didn't meet them in person who ended
up being an actual convicted sexual
offender thank God I didn't fall for the
glitz and the Glam that he was trying to
throw at me because imagine if I did
what would have happened then it would
have got scary
and also to another thing that I've
noticed especially like
from
mid-20s going to like yeah mid to late
20s it's a lot of guys are becoming lazy
and the reason why I say that is because
I don't know if it's because you can get
access to so many women or
um just get access to anything
the
willing to push to like actually put
effort to meet in someone or like
actually come up with an idea be
proactive
is small it's because okay I'll tell you
there's two reasons one it's the 2080
rule so 80 of women are 20 of men have
access to 80 of women because if you ask
80 of women what they want in a man they
list 20 of men so we're all going after
the same guys so it's just supply and
demand those guys can get a lot of girls
a lot proactive men are now disappearing
so a lot of what proactive
you know what I'm a pro I want to call
myself a proactive man but I'm when I'm
proactive
that's just my default position like
some people's default position is not
proactiveness do you know I mean like
some people are
DTF
do you know what I mean like yeah just
down to [ __ ] like it's like oh that's
dude they're not trying to go on days
they're not trying to do all of that but
that's what I said earlier you know you
have to discern who what type of person
are you do you get what I mean you
you're looking at the man but you have
to take accountability for yourself
first and then put forward your best
self I think that's what's happening now
like a lot of times I get confused
that's right and then we've and also
with the men that you're attracting you
have you know if you're attracting the
same type of guy in the same type of guy
in different bodies what is it that
you're putting forth that's allowing
these those men to be in your space
um
um having higher demands of men that
clearly can't perform to that level it's
like a losing battle do you get what I
mean so it's good to have expectation
obviously you have standards but all
your standards realistic do you get what
I mean as as a woman I know I can't go
to a place swear there's Millionaires
and be like yeah I'm demanding this this
and this knowing that I personally am
not up to par you know so it's
accountable can you imagine
one in Princess Behavior or or demanding
princess behavior and you're not my
princess like it doesn't it doesn't make
no sense like you're asking men that you
have no idea about you don't know the
I'm not saying new ladies but I'm just
saying ladies and gentlemen they're
asking men to treat them like a
quote-unquote princess you are not my
princess why am I what obligation do I
have to treat you like my princess I'll
treat you like an individual and a
person with respect but you're not
getting all the glitz and glamor yet
that's that that's earned yeah but
that's why you need to ask sorry to call
you but that's why you need to ask
questions you need to be inquisitive and
understand the person's core values do
they align with your core values what's
the point of being treated like a
princess if that's a temporary day out
it's not realistic do you get what I
mean
all right
no but yeah no it's true because there
are I think now there is this big
dissolution of
ah another thing
some women if something happens to them
once like a guy buys her bunch of
flowers 80 flat 80 roses she
automatically not all of them but quite
a few automatically believe everything
is
I'm thinking Sometimes some and then
when I do talk to like younger guys I'm
like be careful what you do because if
you do it once best relief is going to
ask you to do it again so if you go do
your hand elsewhere once
she's gonna expect you to do it again